today we are creating something
incredible something that i've recently
used in the real world and something
that i wanted to share with you guys so
you can go back and create some
incredible curved architecture
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today if you can't tell i am super
excited about this tutorial we are
creating some elegant curved clean lines
finally in archicad now i know i do a
lot of basic architecture but i really
wanted to push these videos to the next
level as much as possible so today we're
diving in to the complex side of
archicad 25.
okay diving straight into this tutorial
once you have it open we're going to be
using the australian select template
again like always feel free to use
whatever you have available to you once
we have archicad 25 open we're going to
start the same way we start every other
tutorial command 7 or control 7
depending on what system you're on i'm
going to insert a new story below i'm
going to call that footings like i
always do so feel free to skip this
section if you have seen it a million
times before and i appreciate you if you
have 172 mil below in the footings is
our slab plus our footing three meters
to our ground floor then we're going to
create a ground ceiling in this instance
i'm going to call it 500 millimeters to
the next floor which is going to be our
first floor above that we're going to
have our first ceiling which is
effectively also our roof and that roof
will be another 500 millimeters for the
purposes of this i'm just going to leave
these on to showcase what they actually
do in elevations we don't talk about
them too much but we'll go into them a
little bit today so let's simply click
ok let's dive down to our footings layer
double clicking on the footings over
here jumping across to our slab tool
over in the center of the palette so
click once
expanding all the way across if you hit
the tab button it will automatically
jump to our dimensions and we can start
typing for example 25 000 so 25 meters
tab once more let's go 9 000 or 9 meters
and there you see we will have our slab
created i'm just a bit pedantic in my
orientation so i'm going to click ctrl d
to allow me to move this slab to more
the center of these sections and
elevation markers it doesn't really
matter it's just me being pedantic now
by pressing control and the up arrow
we're going to jump all the way up to
our ground floor right clicking on
footings show us trace reference we can
see that we've created our ground slab
next we're going to come over to our
wall tool walls external outside face
generic let's move this down to our 90
ml stud partition
simply drawing a line all the way around
i'm just going to zoom in to showcase
the fact that it's on the opposite side
of this slab so by tapping the p button
it will automatically flip that wall so
that we can hold shift making sure it's
perpendicular finish our walls and have
a perfect box ready to go going to 3d
you'll see that we've started to create
our 3d box
we have our slab that is slightly low so
if we press command t we'll open up our
settings and we can see we're
-172 to the project zero so if we change
that to zero hit okay
our slab will increase in height to
sitting in line with our walls and then
pressing ctrl up and right clicking on
our ground and going show trace
reference here is where we're going to
start the fundamental basics of our
curved design
now what i'm envisioning is one side of
the curve wrapping down falling to the
ground and connecting back to nature
whilst the other one wraps upwards
pointing towards the sky and in turn
we're creating that connection from the
ground all the way to the sky
through elevated elegant curved lines
now to effectively do this i'm going to
go to our slab tool i'm going to use a
generic slab but i'm going to beef it up
quite substantially so if we go command
t we'll open up our settings again we're
going to change the structural composite
and we're going to change that to
concrete so by typing in the letters i
can find my concrete hit enter and i'm
going to make that i want to say 300
millimeters for the time but we might
revisit this soon next i'm going to
click ok and i'm simply going to draw a
slab around this whole section here i'm
clicking on it once again clicking on
the outside edge offsetting all edges
and i'm going to offset let's go 1200 to
make that an easy concrete cantilever
next command down clicking on the
external perimeter of these walls if
they aren't already automatically
grouped alt g will automatically group
those walls so you can go control c
control up up so you see on this side we
move up and down to our next floor and
then ctrl v to paste it in the correct
space so clicking off that to secure and
confirm that we are happy to paste that
in that position coming back to our 3d
to see what's happening and what is
going on now there's a reason these
aren't working correctly in this point
of time because this slab isn't 500 mil
as per
our command 7
ceiling grid spacing so what i want to
do is click on that slab control d click
on one of the external nodes and push it
all the way up to that first floor after
that i want to select the ground floor
walls clicking on the once command t
opens up our wall selection settings and
then i want to increase the top link to
the first floor and make sure that is
zero now i can click ok those walls will
automatically lift up in line with our
walls above going to our ground floor so
we can quickly establish what elevation
we have to go to to understand how we're
going to manipulate our curved facade we
can see it's elevation 3 we need so if i
right click on elevation 3 open with
current view settings and then just
expand that so they all go in this top
tab we're going to see these dashed
lines for starters and this is what i'm
usually talking about by unticking all
of that information on the side so by
pressing ctrl 7 or command 7 you'll see
that by simply unticking all of these
clicking okay all of that information is
quickly going to disappear now some
people like that some people don't
personally i like to change that
information so i untick it but you will
keep it ticked for the purposes of this
video alright so now we see our
elevation and like i was saying we're
going to be connecting the right side to
the ground and expanding up to the
ceiling so this slab protrusion here
might actually be pushed back or it
might fall back to the ground after that
to create a walkway underneath i'm not
sure yet so let's start in the center
here so we can actually create something
a little bit different if you've made it
this far in the video firstly thank you
so much for being a part of this
community it is ever growing thanks to
more and more people seeing the videos
sharing the videos and most importantly
hitting the like button down below
believe it or not that like button and
that like button alone helps with the
youtube algorithm and makes more people
see this content and more people
hopefully get into the architecture
profession or if not better themselves
in the architecture profession whilst
you're down there don't forget about the
links in the description there is one
link down there that will take you to my
website filled with digital downloads
these are absolutely essential for any
architecture student any architect or
any designer working in the architecture
practice it doesn't matter where you're
located from australia to europe to
america or anywhere potentially in india
or asia new zealand the checklist is
universal and will help you get better
at what you're trying to achieve now i'm
going to start this process with a very
simple line tool i'm just going to click
once holding the shift button pressing
the d key and then typing in 2500
gives me the start of my elevated shape
that i'm trying to create and curve next
i'm going to activate my spline tool
clicking on the edge once and simply
clicking two more times
down to the bottom to create a nice
gentle curve falling back
to our floating concrete ceiling now
that we have the fundamental basic shape
created this can work with a million
other shapes if you want to create
something funky go for your life you can
create almost anything your heart
imagines
we're going to copy these two lines by
pressing ctrl c and then we're going to
come up to options complex profiles
profile manager and we're going to
create a brand new profile so i'm going
to call that curved
up and click ok i'm going to move this
just to the side and then i'm going to
command or control paste my curved line
in the centers perfectly fine clicking
ok justifying that it goes there and
then i'm going to move the bottom the
top of this line to this red x now it
isn't really critical if it's the top or
the bottom we can manipulate that later
but i just want to have one of those
points on that x marker now we're going
to select this top linear line click
click control d then press the control
button again to activate the multiplier
tool hold shift from memory our concrete
slab was 300 millimeters so i'm going to
move it 300 millimeters across the
spline below i'm going to offset tap
control once 300 millimeters so that it
offsets at a perfect 300 millimeters
from
that shape there
finally i'm going to hold the alt button
to be able to quickly and easily
replicate that line tool
join these two ends together and then
scroll down to find my fill tool holding
the space bar
and clicking in the center of that line
to automatically fill the space now
we'll click on that fill again and look
up the top here so it says
tile floor we're not wanting a tile
floor just like our concrete wall we're
going to change that to concrete
structural and as you'll see all that
feel will change it'll become something
very different in the final product
finally before we finish up here we want
to make sure that it's on our wall tool
and we click the save button and all we
have to do now is click close so let's
come back into our ground ceiling now to
start creating that first shape the
ground ceiling up the top and seeing
where our wall is i'm going to go to the
wall tool
making sure it's on external i'm going
to select my curved geometry and instead
of having the basic shapes i'm going to
change my shapes to complex profiles and
select curved up the rest of this we can
manipulate as we go along in 3d we're
not going to worry too much about all
the nitty gritty details and the finer
story settings we're just simply going
to click on this wall i'm going to
extend that let's say 1500 radius and
then i'm going to draw a half moon now i
know straight away that this is
potentially going to be the wrong way
around but it's a very simple fix so
let's first of all locate it roughly
where we want on this building let's say
jumping back into 3d we're going to see
an upside down concave instead of what
we actually envisioned so simply tapping
the p button is going to flip that to
the perfect space that we want with this
selected we're simply going to click
ctrl d move it up in the line with our
concrete slab and then we're going to
click control d again
and then we're going to go to our ground
ceiling click on the complex profile
we've created command d control d
whatever system you're on dragging it
out to the front of our slab now to
remove this section the simplest way is
clicking on the slab coming across to
our insert new node and repeating the
same step for those two sections there i
believe that this is where our cutoff is
and where it falls away so this is
probably the best spot for it clicking
once more in the center changing to a
curved edge and replicating to the edge
checking in 3d that we've done the right
thing yes that is exactly where slab
stops and our wall starts so that is
absolutely perfect next i'm going to
click on this these four walls pressing
alt g escape once clicking on that wall
again to make sure it's ungrouped i'm
going to right click it connect solid
element operations
and it'll automatically set it as the
target i'm going to use this as the
operator then i'm going to subtract the
downwards extrusion and hit execute what
you'll see is that wall will be
perfectly cut in line with that curved
concrete blade
so what we've effectively started to do
is we've started to create this concave
curved structure moving up and i've just
noticed that the ceiling below isn't
in-field so i'm simply going to click on
the edge of that click the plus button
and just drag that back there now that
is a beautiful first start to this
project we are touching and reaching for
the sky but we aren't connecting back to
the ground so what we're going to do is
we're going to come back into our
elevation
and we are going to simply replicate
that same line that we created somewhere
over here i'm going to press command e
to turn on the rotation tool holding the
shift button i'm going to rotate it a
full 90 degrees
keeping that exact same pattern over
here might work really really well then
i'm going to return back to my straight
geometric shape clicking on the edge and
coming to 3d to see what we have drawn
we have drawn another curve up which
isn't what we're looking for so let's go
options complex profiles profile manager
curved up and
duplicate curved renaming it to curved
down pressing okay pressing edit
and then all we're going to do is simply
press command m to mirror this design
and command m to mirror it once more
starting from that top node here we
don't need that anymore let's click save
close and then finally changing our wall
from curve up to curve down so there you
go now we can press ctrl or command d
lower that
to the edge of our
blade wall
and we finally have
our wall curving from the ground back up
and now we have our blade starting from
the ground coming all the way up and
then swooping all the way to the sky the
fundamental basics of this video have
been covered but now we're going to turn
this ordinary looking box into something
architectural and something magnificent
so let's get into that section of this
tutorial jumping up to the first floor
we are going to right click our ground
ceiling show as trace reference
selecting our furthest wall control d
let's move that back i'm gonna guess
here let's go eight meters back holding
the control button clicking on the
additional walls getting rid of those
walls
we're gonna see that box jump right back
in now i simply want to create a whole
glass box down the bottom and a timber
floating blocks box up the top so alt g
re-link those walls command t let's
override the front surface with some
vertical walnut pressing okay
we have some beautiful vertical walnuts
sitting on top of this concrete floating
roof coming down to our ground floor
we're going to go to our window tool and
we're literally just going to make this
whole wall one large window so let's
start by connecting it dragging it all
the way out making sure our node
extender is there clicking ok and coming
back to 3d to see what we've drawn
next clicking on that window extending
the height both ways up and down so it
is a floor to ceiling glass frame
command t control t override object line
types click
and change to black as you know i hate
the orange lines they drive me crazy
override pen lines as well you'll see
all the changes happening right for your
eyes now coming across to our basic
window settings we're just simply going
to click across until we get to our
sashes and we're going to introduce a
custom hv grid clicking on our front
view so we see what's going on so
because this is almost 25 meters long i
want to have 24 horizontal separations
and i want to have zero vertical
separations so it's just that continuous
nice glass look i do also want to click
on that again control command t
and change our model attributes so i
don't want aluminium windows you guys
know i like black frame windows quickly
and easily changes all of them pressing
ok
coming to our ground floor zooming in
holding alt so we can easily replicate
that on this side of the wall
and selecting the window control command
d
sliding it across
repeating that step on both the side
elevations and changing the amount of
mullions depending on the length of the
wall
okay so there we have a full glass
bottom box we have our concrete curved
wall a concrete curved i'll call it a
roof and our timber box above i am going
to simply just drop in a concrete roof
above it's not going to be anything
special we're not going to work on it
too hard but just so from a practical
point of view you would know there is
some sort
of actual roof above so coming back to
our first floor going to our window tool
and selecting our window somewhere in
here we have the starting of our window
that is obviously
way too many mullions for what we need
i am going to extend the window as a
simple 500 millimeter highlight
and extend it to our curved up wall now
i don't want that many transitions and
that many mullions in this window so
ctrl t again coming up to our sash
options and let's change that to half of
what we usually would have so five gives
you a very premium luxury looking window
repeating that on one more side up here
on the left and there we go now we have
our architectural foundational base that
we can take into twin motion render out
we can create a floor plan interior we
can create an upstairs living space
bedroom sleeping quarters we can do
anything with this design
if you do want a copy of this archicad
file it is available to all patreon
members through the links down below
it'll redirect you to the discord group
chat where you'll have exclusive private
use of the all access area and you can
download this file whenever you want to
keep working on it anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching the video i hope you enjoyed it
i genuinely do hope you learned
something new and are going to take this
into your own practice into your own
architecture and create something unique
and truly special if you did make sure
you smash that like button down below
like i already said it helps with the
algorithm it helps me know that you
enjoy this content and want to see me
create more if you do want to see more
of this content make sure you also
subscribe to the channel because every
single monday i drop a new video be it
an archicad tutorial or something
technology related usually within the
architecture space but like i said that
is all for me today so thank you so much
for watching and like always i'll see
you next monday